you know why so few people make money
investing because they invest based on
their emotions or their friends opinion
and they don't hang out with rich people
so their friend is a broke person who
has an opinion about money if you invest
based on your emotions or makeup based
on your broke friends opinion you're
gonna be broke your whole life because
you're not going to be investing or
you're gonna be buying at the wrong
times and buying when it's high and
selling when it's low that's what's
happening right now if you've not been
under a rock you've heard someone panic
about the stock market in the past two
or three days don't panic invest you
know what rich people are doing when the
stock market goes down buying when the
stock market goes down they increase
their investments in the mutual funds
that's what rich people are doing you
know what poor people are doing freaking
out and taking their money out at the
exact wrong time to take their money out
of something and you know when they'll
get back in when the market is hot again
it's back up so they will buy high and
sell low you're supposed to buy low and
sell high that's how this works if it
works but instead of using historical
data instead of using a systematic
approach to long-term vision investing
we invest based on the emotions of our
stupid friends or the stupid newscaster
I had every News Network calling me
right now I want me to appearance
tonight talk about the crash of the
stock market oh brother
I'll probably be on one of them
depending on I've got a dinner tonight
I'm going to but I probably only want
them if I can tape it I'll let you know
later in the show if I know what it is
but the stock markets not crashing Oh
what about 2008 what about are you
living for
18,000 to 6300 now in that a crash no
that's a start marking more than half a
crash is something that's worth noting
when your money is worth I lost all my
money in the doctor it's impossible for
you to lose all your money in the stock
market your money might have gone in
half if you bought at the exact top of
the market of the last market slide in
the 2008 debacle and you sold it the
exact bottom of the market you lost half
of your money exactly because it was six
was right out exactly means it went from
$14,000 $6,300 what's that it's a little
over half like fifty three percent or
something right oh by the way what was
the Dow last week before all this
happened eighteen thousand it wasn't
sixty three hundred did you hear anybody
on the news talking about it going from
sixty three hundred increasing three
hundred percent to eighteen thousand
since the bottom was anybody standing
out in the street yelling among your
friends going no one was doing that they
don't do that it's not human nature
instead they go it's going up but you
know what it's kind of fall that's kind
of fall it's gonna fall
human nature is its gonna fall it's
gonna fall has to fall something bad has
to happen that's your manager and you
know you're just gonna be broke darling
if you do that your whole life you're
just gonna be broke the only way you
make money investing in mutual funds or
in any kind of market real estate is you
buy all the time you buy one it's up you
buy one it's down you keep buying and
you keep buying you keep buying overall
the move in the market is upward overall
but does the market go up and does the
market go down yes it does but overall
the market has moved way up since it
began it's averaged right out of 12
percent annual return that's the sp500
growth is an average of a 12 percent
rate of return that's the average now if
you know anything about mathematics the
average is the total divided by the
number of years that's the average which
means that a certain number we're below
12%
number we're above 12% in order to get
an average of 12% if you did your math
homework in the 6th grade you know how
to do that and that's how an average
comes about so here's the deal
start market opened this morning and
Dovie 1100 points at the beginning of
trading which means it's almost back to
where it started this year mm-hmm yeah
i'ma try that again
it's almost as low as it was at the
beginning of the year a year ago it's a
52-week low the beginning of this time
last year I guess is the proper
terminology a year ago that's where it
was so it's also if you put money in a
year ago and your money in there today
you broke even
you people are losing your freaking
minds chill out kind of never saw so
many crazy people on Twitter in my life
yourself now aren't you no no I'm gonna
show you myself on my same to you but
I'm not saying to myself I'm buying
today while it's down I'll be buying
tomorrow and when it's up I'll be buying
and I buy every month I buy stock every
our with mutual funds
I put stock on Twitter this morning but
you'll both look well I Bob stock their
mutual funds so shut up okay so but
listen here's the deal nobody gets hurt
on a rollercoaster if they don't jump
off and the only time it takes your
stomach on a rollercoaster
puts it up in your throat this money's
going down remember going up is boring
you know what that rollercoaster sounds
like right when it's going up it's
another little track thing going up
right that's boring nobody gets excited
about it going on even if it spikes up
even if it went up 500 points some day
nobody gets excited about that boy let
it turn down a couple times and let some
unknown the Chinese economy woo there's
a boogeyman Chinese economy is going to
take us down fears on the Chinese
economy fear is that the
these are going to continue to melt down
their currency fears that the United
States of America is going to collapse
man what are you people smoking honestly
you live your lives in fear don't be so
afraid an investor that makes money in
the market gets in the market and stays
in the market they don't jump in they
don't jump out and they don't panic you
don't get hurt on a rollercoaster if you
don't jump off I know it's scary but I'm
making fun of you for being scared
because the history is that it comes
back and I'm the guy that was standing
out there the whole time the market was
dropping from 14,000 all the way down to
6300 I'm the guy that was out there
yelling don't take your money out don't
take your money out don't take your
money out don't take your money out
it'll come back don't take your money
out I'm that guy it not only came back
from 6300 to 14000 and all the way to
18,000 and now we're down around the
15,000 and some change or whatever we
land today so I'll say it again
don't take your money out just keep
investing this is what rich people did
if you listen to your broke friends and
the drama queens on the news channels
you're gonna be broke your whole
freaking life don't listen to that stuff
long-term investors are the ones that
make money